- [Narrator] Covering a
half-acre with hanging flowers,
the oldest known wisteria in Japan
is the centerpiece of this brilliantly
pastel-colored flower park.
Located in Tochigi, Japan, just over
an hour train ride from Tokyo,
is Ashikaga Flower Park.
The park spans 23 acres and is home
to more than 350 wisterias
and other flowers.
The colors vary depending
on the flowering season,
from pinks and purples,
to yellows and whites.
Some features of the park include
the wisteria tunnel and floating gardens,
but the pride and joy
of Ashikaga Flower Park
is the Great Miracle Wisteria.
The 140-year-old sprawling tree
is located in a place of pride,
right in the center of the park.
After nightfall, the site is lit up
so these draping flowers
can be seen at all hours.
The vivid yellow wisteria begins blooming
at the start of May and is the only one
of its kind in Japan.
The park is a year-round attraction
with seasonal plants that creates
an ever-changing sense of magnificence
as nature puts on a show.
(casual upbeat background music)